george eustis is here with us now
environment secretary of course i think
i might say you're supporting grant
shaps that's right yes i think he would
take part in our debate i'm sure he
would i mean as you know grant shaps has
never been shy in terms of coming out
all the media rounds often on difficult
days in fact one of the reasons i'm
supporting him
is firstly i've seen him in cabinet over
the last two years and i think he's
shown a good judgement i've often been
in cobra meetings with him and we've had
for instance issues around
the short straights and transport and
getting goods into the country and i
think he's always dealt with what's
thrown his way very very well but also
he's always been willing to go out and
uh back for government on difficult days
when we have those uh difficult times
i've i've always done that he has too so
i'm sure he would take part in that
debate yes why him
over others because i mean it's fair to
say he's not a frontrunner is he well
look i've always taken the view uh in
leadership
campaigns and this is the fourth one
that i've seen now that actually what
you should do is uh decide who you think
is the best candidate out of the field
and there are many good talented
candidates they've all got their
strengths but my view is that grant
shaps is the best man to become our
leader and our prime minister at this
particular point he's got cabinet
experience over uh um several different
leaders he's shown very good judgments
uh in my view
he's a very good communicator he did a
stint as party chairman so he's a good
campaigner and we're going to need
someone who can campaign as we go into
the next uh next general election so i
just think he's got all of the strengths
and the experience that we need at this
particular time and that's why i'm
backing him who else would you fold in
behind
i'm not getting into that i generally
take the view that i pick the candidate
that i think should win and i give it my
all to help them win uh if something
goes wrong along the way well then i'll
probably uh you know privately decide
what to do at that point but at the
moment uh we're talking to lots of
people we're getting lots of interest in
his campaign
i think he's only just launched
yesterday but i think he's a very very
strong candidate and i hope that we can
get him that through to that final
run-off for party members looks like
it's already getting ugly
well we tend to get this sort of uh uh
joshing during any any sort of
leadership campaign as i said the first
one i did was when we got david cameron
elected it was a little bit similar then
but i he came through the field though
didn't he i mean he wasn't a
front-runner uh that's all right he
wasn't a front-runner and that's why i
don't believe um any mps should sit on
their hands and wait to see which way
the wind's blowing or declare early
because they think someone's going to
win and they just want to
show their support for who they deem to
be the probable winner it's always the
right thing to do
to make sure that you put your support
behind the candidate that you believe in
and not be shy of coming out publicly
and saying so in the first round and
that's why i'm doing it now for grant
shaps because i think he's the best
candidate
i'm not going to sit on my hands and say
well who might win and who might be in
the final round and will he get support
i'm going to get out there and help him
get that support because i'm confident
he's the right person to do it seems a
bit unseemly doesn't it 12.
am i 11 so far probably 12 when pretty
patel um maybe throws a hat into the
ring later on today how are you going to
whittle it down well it is a very wide
field there's no doubt about that and um
the party does have a process for for
whittling it down so there will they
every candidate will need to get you
know a small number of mps to get
nominated and then at home and it used
to be eight i think wasn't it i think it
has been 12 it could be 30. well no it
will be for the 1922 committee to decide
the rules i suspect that they will keep
at the numbers for nominations uh you
know reasonably low so that everybody
gets a chance
well i don't know it's not i'm not on
the 1922 committee they'll decide but
but i would read reports in the paper
that it could be up to 30 you don't
think it'll be that um well i don't
think it should be that because i think
actually what they um what everyone
deserves is a run at the leadership in
the first round whether they then have a
threshold above which you've got to get
in that first round i think that's a
different matter so we might see several
candidates locked out in the first round
and then of course the the exhaustive
ballot process as it's called where you
just keep eliminating uh the final
runner and their votes get redistributed
to the next round that can be done
actually very quickly you can condense
that into a few days if you need to you
do need to we will need to um because i
i think um it's generally accepted that
we should conclude the parliamentary
phases of this uh before summer recess
so that which is a week on wednesday
exactly over the next couple of weeks we
want to to get this concluded and that
can absolutely be done uh through that
exhaustive ballot process you you can
hold several ballots in in one day if
you want to so the 1922 committee uh and
segregated brady will obviously be
working out what the rules should be
but i absolutely think yes it's uh it's
doable it's a tight timetable uh it
means people have a short period of time
to make their case uh but i'm here today
to make that case for grant chaps okay
um it does seem with all of the runners
and riders that there was an awful lot
of pent-up frustration as far as this
prime minister is concerned all of these
people now wanting his job why did you
stick by him
look i didn't campaign for boris johnson
in the last uh leadership campaign in
2019 i campaigned as you might remember
for michael gove at that time um and i i
thought i knew all of um boris johnson's
strengths and his weaknesses and when he
offered me a place in his government
i've always thought it's really
important that when the party makes a
decision on a leader that you all rally
around and you pull back together and
you work as a team and that's what i've
done and so i
worked and showed support for the
government the conservative government
to deliver our agenda indeed that is
what
every other cabinet minister also did
yes all of them would have had some of
the differences with the prime minister
all of them would have had things they
wanted done slightly differently but we
were all working as a team to deliver
for that conservative manifesting sure
but if they hadn't had the nerve people
like seti javid um and uh rishi sunak to
break ranks we would still have the
prime minister imposed
well i think it was coming to a head
because almost certainly
the party was heading for another
confidence vote in the prime minister
probably would have happened this week
and actually probably would have
happened even if no one uh had resigned
and he probably would have lost at that
point so i think um it came
to the to a point where cabinet members
even those like me who were loyal to him
even grant shaps who were loyal to the
government and wanted us to hold
together we all realized uh at that
point that he just had lost the
confidence of the party and then you
couldn't carry on prime ministers are
not directly elected it's not a
presidential system uh they they exist
and they're there uh you know only while
they have the support of parliament in
general and in particular of course the
vast majority of mps on their own
benches because prime ministers can't
get anything done without that and i
think once it was clear that he no
longer had that um many cabinet
ministers spoke to him or spoke to his
team or spoke to the chief whip to say
uh you know that the time is up he's
going to have to
resign and i'm pleased that's what he
did you know he reflected on that advice
that he had from cabinet ministers and
chose to step down on his own terms when
will we know who the next prime minister
is
um it will probably
uh be i would imagine sometime in
september
um the 1922 committee and the
conservative party will obviously need
to announce the the rules but they'll be
the parliamentary rounds over the next
two weeks so we'll be down to probably
just two candidates by the end of next
week and then those two candidates will
go out on a series of hustings around
the country during august possibly early
september as well i would imagine at
some time
you know middle of september perhaps
we'll have a new leader in place yeah
after they've ripped lumps out of each
other let's see what happens it's good
to talk to you well it's very important
that people you know we're all
colleagues and we're going to have to
pull back together and work together
very important people people work
sensibly okay for now thanks very much
indeed thank you